T
OFF.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT,
QUESTIONS TO PONDER.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
LOT OF FINGER POINTING CONTINUES
TONIGHT IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
HERE AT THE ANGLE WE'RE LESS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FINGER
POINTING AND HOW TO GET BETTER
RESULTS.
LOTS OF BUZZ AND CHANGES TO THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP AFTER MORE
DISAPPOINTING NEWS OVER THE
WEEKEND AND TONIGHT OUT OF
NEVADA AND ARIZONA.
AS MUCH AS THE GRASSROOT WANTS
OTURN THE ENTIRE PARTY UPSIDE
DOWN, THEY NEED TO BE REALISTIC
ABOUT THE LANDSCAPE.
YOU CAN'T BEAT SOMETHING WITH
NOTHING.
WHOEVER IS IN CHARGE, WILL HAVE
TO LAY OUT THE GROUNDWORK NOW
FOR A FAR MORE SOPHISTICATED
CAMPAIGN IN 2024.
IF YOU WANT TO LEAD THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY YOU NEED TO
ANSWER TOUGH QUESTIONS.
FIRST, I CAN COMPLAIN ABOUT IT,
EVEN IN SOME REPUBLICAN STATES,
BALLOT HARVESTING IS LEGAL IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT'S LEGAL IN DOZENS OF STATES.
BALLOT HARVESTING IS WHEN A
THIRD PARTY CAN COLLECT AND
BRING IN BALLOTS FOR A VOTER.
WHY AREN'T THE REPUBLICANS
BETTER AT IT?
WHAT ARE THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
GROUPS DOING IT NOW.
WHAT ARE REPUBLICANS DOING TO
EMULATE THE SUCCESSFUL METHODS?
SECOND, AS MUCH AS WE ALL WISH
VOTING WAS LIMITED TO ONE DAY,
EARLY VOTING IS PROBABLY HERE TO
STAY.
WHAT LEADERSHIP PROPOSING THAT
THEIR STATE OFFICIALS DO TO GET
BETTER AT THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW HOW TO GAME
THE SYSTEM.
UNTIL REPUBLICANS CAN CHANGE
ELECTION LAWS, THEY NEED TO BEAT
THE DEMOCRATS AT THEIR OWN GAME.
OTHERWISE, HOW ARE THEY GOING TO
AVOID SCENES LIKE THIS.
>> CLARK COUNTY THERE WERE
22,000 VOTES THERE.
>> 85,000 VOTES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
>> PIMA COUNTY, WE GOT ANOTHER
BATCH OF 24,000 VOTES.
>> THERE WAS A DUMP OF 3379
VOTES.
>> Laura: EXCEPT IN STATES LIKE
FLORIDA, SOUTH DAKOTA, DEMOCRATS
HAVE THE EARLY VOTING FIELD TO
THEMSELVES.
THIRD, GOING FORWARD, BECAUSE OF
THE EARLY VOTING AND MAIL-IN
BALLOTS, WE HAVE TO ASSUME THAT
IN MANY CASE, IT WILL TAKE AT
LEAST TWO WEEKS TO COUNT THE
VOTES.
IN STATES LIKE ILLINOIS, BALLOTS
HAVE TWO WEEKS TO A ARRIVE AS
LONG AS THEY ARE POSTMARKED BY
ELECTION DAY.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IN WASHINGTON STATE, BY THE WAY,
IT'S THREE WEEKS.
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO ENSURE
THAT GOP INTEREST DURING THIS
PROCESS ARE BEING PROTECTED
DURING THESE LONG AND EXTENDED
VOTE PERIODS?
SHOULDN'T THEY BE DOING MORE?
WHY ISN'T THERE A GOP WEBSITE
THAT ALLOWS US TO TRACK IN
REALTIME HOW MANY VOTES ARE
LEFT.
WHO'S DOING THE COUNTS?
FOR THE PAST SIX DAYS,
REPUBLICAN FRIENDS, THEY KEEP
TEXTING ME SAYING, LAURA WHAT IS
HAPPENING?
ARE WE GOING TO WIN IN ARIZONA?
IT'S A FEELING OF TOTAL
HELPLESSNESS BECAUSE THEY ARE
LEFT IN THE DARK.
THIS YEAR, REPUBLICANS LOST
SENATE RACES IN ARIZONA,
CALIFORNIA, HAWAII, NEVADA,
OREGON AND WASHINGTON STATE OUT
WEST.
WE LOST SENATE RACES IN
CONNECTICUT, MARYLAND, NEW
HAMPSHIRE, PENNSYLVANIA, NEW
YORK AND VERMONT.
WE WON EVERY OTHER SENATE RACE
WITH LONE EXCEPTION OF GEORGIA,
WHICH IS A RUNOFF AND ILLINOIS
BECAUSE OF CHICAGO AND COLORADO,
DENVER GONE LEFT.
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING REALLY
WELL IN MIDDLE AMERICA.
WHAT IS THE SPECIFIC PLAN TO DO
BETTER ALONG THE TWO COASTS?
YOU GOT 12 SENATE SEATS IN NEW
ENGLAND.
THIS YEAR THE GOP CONTINUES TO
PROVE WE HAVE LOT OF SUPPORT IN
THE LATINO COMMUNITY.
THAT BLOCK STILL SUPPORT
DEMOCRATS BY A MARGIN 2-1.
SIXTH, IF THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THE NOMINATED CANDIDATES WHO
DONORS WANTED, WEREN'T NOMINATED
AND OTHERS WERE WEAK, WHY DID
ADAM WAXHAW LOSE IN NEVADA.
WHERE IS SHE STRUGGLING IN
ALASKA.
YOU KNOW THAT DEMOCRATS WANT TO
DO THAT.
NEXT T WHAT BENEFITS DID THE GOP
GET FROM MITCH McCONNELL'S
DECISION TO LET THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
BILL CASSIDY CLAIMED TO ME THAT
BILL WILL GIVE THE REPUBLICANS
MORE LEVERAGE TO STOP THE
CLIMATE CHANGE BILL.
WELL, THE OPPOSITE HAPPENED.
IT GAVE THE DEMOCRATS A
POLITICAL VICTORY TO RUN ON THIS
SEASON.
WHAT THE HECK DID WE GET OUT OF
IT?
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER SENATE
MITCHMcCONNELL, HE SAID ALMOST
NOTHING DURING THE CAMPAIGN WHEN
HE CRITICIZED REPUBLICAN
NOMINEES.
WHAT ARE THE ADVANTAGES OF
HAVING A SENATE LEADER WHO
DOESN'T SPEAK MUCH, ESPECIALLY
WHEN GOP VOTERS ARE RESTLESS AND
ANGRY.
I DON'T KNOW, THE QUIET
APPROACH.
LOOKING AT THESE RESULTS, MOST
OF OBSERVERS WILL LIKELY
CONCLUDE THAT PELOSI, EVEN
THOUGH SHE WILL NARROWLY LOSE
HER MAJORITY, AND SCHUMER WHO
WILL HANG ON BARELY, THEY ARE
BETTER AT POLITICS.
SADLY THAN McCARTHY AND
McCONNELL.
WHY ARE THOSE OBSERVERS WRONG?
AGAIN, WE NEED A REAL
CONVERSATION HERE.
THERE'S NO SHYING AWAY FROM IT.
SOMEHOW, DESPITE DEMOCRATS
LEAVING US WITH 8% INFLATION,
SPIKE IN CRIME, AND AN OPEN
BORDER, MILLIONS OF VOTERS IN
BATTLEGROUND STATES DIDN'T BLAME
THEM FOR IT.
WHAT THREE THINGS DO REPUBLICANS
STAND FOR RIGHT NOW THAT THE
LEADERSHIP CAN ARTICULATE WITH
CLARITY, SPECIFICITY AND
CONVICTION?
IS IT OPENING UP IMMEDIATE
DRILLING AND FRACKING TO BRING
DOWN ENERGY COST.
IS IT MIDDLE CLASS TAX CUTS?
WE HAVE LOT OF QUESTIONS.
WHOEVER WANTS TO LEAD THE GOP
SHOULD BE GIVING US ANSWERS.
LET'S NOT FORGET, WE'VE HAD
SUCCESSES IN THE HISTORY BOOK,
2022 WILL PROBABLY BE REMEMBERED
AS THE YEAR ROE V. WADE WAS
OVERTURNED.
AS THE NEAR NANCY PELOSI LOST
THE HOUSE.
IT MAYBE REMEMBERED AS THE YEAR
THE DEMOCRATS LOST FLORIDA FOR
GOOD.
THE YEAR THAT REPUBLICANS
STARTED SHOWING NEW LIFE IN NEW
YORK, HUGE VICTORY THERE.
THOSE ARE GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
AS WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU, IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO KEEP WINNING THE
SAME STATES OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WE NEED LEADERS WHO WANT TO DO
BETTER AND WHO CAN HELP US GROW
THIS MOVEMENT.
WE'LL LOOK FOR THEM UNTIL WE